aujourd'hui c'est la pole day c'est le
jour où apple fait ses grosses annonces
matériel gross qui note de rentrée du
mois de septembre qui arrivait un peu
plus tôt d'ailleurs que les années
précédentes
alors aujourd'hui on va venir ce pas
être tout de suite dans cette vidéo des
mondes connectés d'apple parce qu'une
grosse annonce il ya vraiment un peu
retourné le truc alors il ya une autre
vidéo où on parle d iphone donc je vous
invite à venir la regarder mais dans
cette vidéo tout de suite on se parle
les appels watch et franchement regardez
déjà on vous montre comme ça apple watch
ultra ce qu'une nouveauté c'est
complètement dingue on y va
[Musique]
alors avant qu'on se parle de la paloise
ultra et d'autres fous furieux et de
nouvelles cibles que viendra y est apple
jeu qu'on se parle de l'apple world
series 8 l'apple watch series 1000
succède à la paloise chérissent edge pas
vous faire le pitch complet de cette
monde c'est pas le truc il ya une mise à
jour vers plus de performances et des
nouveautés on voit la terre ça vous
c'est joli on garde le même design le
design change absolument pas l'écran
légèrement incurvé bon on a les mêmes
modes qu'on connaît voilà y'a un truc
est tout nouveau alors attrayante et ne
pas le voir ce que l'on ya beaucoup de
textes je vous montre c'est surtout
qu'il ya un capteur de température qui
sont venus mettre dans la montre alors
attendez à l'écran auquel il nous parle
un peu du truc la résistance à l'eau la
résistance aux chutes la certification
la poussière broc et voilà c'est toute
la côte et santé effectivement qu'elle
nous intéressait mais nous voilà le
découvre et le capteur de température
alors le capteur de température il est
intéressant et j'ai trouvé ça vachement
intéressant qu'apple vient de nous en
parler parce qu'en fait apple en parle
au travers du cycle menstruel et pas
d'autre chose j'aurais adoré voyez on
est en poste un peu posco vie danse pas
complètement fini l'histoire mais
j'espère on croise les doigts mais
évidemment et bien j'aurais bien aimé
capel nous disent eh bien vous sentez
pas bien ou sentent un peu mal attaf
capteurs de température vous prenez
votre température vous mesurez vos
grades et où est-ce que vous en êtes et
vous savez je trouve ça génial manon
alors non alors bon peut-être qu'on peut
le faire je regarderai on testera donc
venez vous abonner s'est pas déjà fait
puis actionnez la cloche pour être
notifié dès qu une prochaine vidéo
arrivera mais surtout regarder il nous
le marquis si vous disposez d'une vue
complète de votre cycle menstruel et il
nous parle bien évidemment de
l'ovulation si vous voyez le mot clé
vous me le dites il est là en fait ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que lorsque on
vient ovuler alors pas moi je suis jeune
homme mais lorsqu'une femme vient au but
mais est bien elle va avoir un petit
monter un petit plateau de température
qui va être un peu plus haut et à eux
ils vont venir détecter cette petite
phrase de températures un peu plus élevé
pour vous dire ok ok là tu en train de
violer de gimont alerte alors à priori
joint tout un travail algorithmique qui
dirait alors attendez on va différencier
sac du moment vous allez faire du sport
du moment où vous avez à bouger
davantage et où on va venir chauffer
davantage ils vont pouvoir moduler ce
petit plateau pour dire ok c'est bon tu
as vu le tu peux y aller bon ok why not
to ta super qui prennent ça sous cet
angle là et qu'ils le présentent comme
ça mais je me dis que sur la donnée de
santé c'est peut-être pas là dessus
qu'il aurait fallu le prendre alors
est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas voulu dire
maintien vous êtes malade on regarde
votre température quelques ponts sports
21 vous avez couru vous montrent un peu
plus en température est ce qu'il ya un
intérêt des abattages suis monté agence
a rien à 37,8 parce que j'ai couru comme
un taré j'en sais rien je sais pas en
tout cas il vous le propose comme ça il
le présente comme sa chance à très bien
est ce que c'est fiable jean qu'ils ont
fait toutes les études derrière pour
venir le vérifier mais bon voilà en tout
cas c'est là elles se savent vraiment
intéressant il vous le montre un moyen
simple d'estimé votre date d'ovulation
date d'ovulation et d'estimé votre
ovulation a probablement eu lieu le
vendredi 2 septembre et peuvent pas vous
prédire vous à l'eau vue et non parce
qu'ils viennent mesurait température
pour qu'ils peuvent parler uniquement
d'un fait qui s'est passé ce qui est
déjà très bien donc il vous parle de la
prédiction des règles parce qu'elles ne
sont pas toujours immuable bon alors
après les tours de données de santé 1
sur le sommeil les trucs un drame ça
c'est pas nouveau le taux d'oxygène dans
le sang c'est des choses qu'on avait
déjà bref donc on passe un peu
l'histoire et surtout un gros focus qui
est fait au niveau de la sécurité sous
ça vachement bien si vous avez un
accident c'est la détection d'accident
ils l'ont montré sur les iphone il le
met également ici en fait vers une
amélioration au niveau du gyroscope et
au niveau de l'accéléromètre qui vont
pouvoir venir détecter des accidents
donc si vous cartonnez en voiture en
moto ou je ne sais quoi et bien ils vont
pouvoir appeler les secours et vous
allez pouvoir être secourues parce que
les secours recevant votre position si
ça nous est super intéressant qu'en fait
voyez ces objets connectés ils sont là
pour rendre notre vie plus simple cela
pour l'améliorer ils sont là pour vous
permettre d'aller beaucoup plus loin au
niveau du sport au niveau de la santé
mais également table de sécurité on a
déjà la détection de chute maintenant on
a la détection des accidents est ce que
ce n'est pas très rassurant après il ya
plein de choses à haut niveau du sport
itinéraire de course qui va arriver
bientôt il ya notre mode qu'ils ont
rajouté c'est un mode d'économie
d'énergie appelle ça le low power mode
on va pouvoir me remonter jusqu'à 36
heures d'autonomie l'idée est pas mal
c'est de se dire ok effectivement
mathias et je suis dans un long voyage
que je suis en avion je peux pas
forcément bien de recharger comme je le
souhaiterais et bien le monde va pouvoir
consommer moins parce que on va venir
enlever le always on display on va
enlever cette application qui vous
travaillez en tâche de fond pour nier
améliorer l'autonomie de votre monde
connecté là vous avez le tarif on
commence à partir de 499 euros tout en
sachant que l'apple watch série 7 qu'on
avait donc l'année dernière commençait à
429 euros on prend donc une augmentation
de génération en génération de 70 euros
alors puisque je vous parle de montres
on va voir celle là également la paix
watch est ce c'est la mise à jour en
fait de l'emploi dsce ce qu'on avait
avant qu'ils avaient adoré que sont
toujours très intéressante parce que si
on n'a pas quasiment 500 euros à mettre
dans une monde connecté là vous êtes à
299 euros c'était le même tarif qu'on
avait avant et vous allez pouvoir
trouver l'essentiel de la paix watch
c'est à dire qu'à des fonctionnalités
que vous n'aurez pas mais vous aurez
vraiment l'essentiel et tout ce qui
conviendra dans cette montre alors elle
va être améliorée bien évidemment on va
retrouver toutes les fonctions
essentielles le sport cies et ça bref
vous en passe et des meilleurs vous et
surtout avoir 20 points sens de
performances en plus par rapport à la
génération précédente et la détection
d'un accident qui est incorporé
directement dans cette monde parce
qu'apple n'a pas voulu faire de
concessions en terme de sécurité et
surtout la grosse annonce c'est celle là
c'est l'apple watch ultra ça tout
nouveau modèle qui vient en fait
s'attaquer à un secteur sur lequel apple
était présent à moitié apple avec ses
apple watch est présent sur toutes les
personnes qui aiment faire du sport donc
si vous aimez courir autour d'un stade
j'en sais rien à faire des tours en
aussi c'est votre claque on pense pas
mon truc mais si c'est votre point fr si
vous voulez aller en salle de sport si
vous allez à la piscine quelles que
soient les sports vous allez faire qu'on
va plus faire quand on est urbain voire
même par la campagne why not eh bien on
peut les faires actions apple watch
quelle qu'elle soit que ce soit la punch
et ce soit la paloise chéri 8 et les
générations d'avant mais là on va
repousser les limites très clairement et
vous le marquis si c'est à dire combien
s'attaquer à notre segment on vient plus
s'attaquer à des garmin on va beaucoup
plus loin on doit beaucoup plus haut
avec une montre alors je vous le montre
tout le tarif vous allez voir ne prenez
pas peur restait assis accrochez-vous on
est sur une montre qui coûte
999 euros attendent attendent l était
pas faite pour vous ça c'est vraiment
une monde pour les personnes qui ont des
vrais besoins très exigeant ce qui peut
être pas votre cas première d'en faire
un petit tour ensemble vous allez voir
on parle vraiment de l' aventure des
aventuriers j'ai pensé aux gens qui vont
faire du travail aux personnes qui vont
faire de la plongée vraiment profondeur
à des personnes qui ont des besoins très
exigeants toutes les personnes qui vont
faire de l' escalade brèche parce que
vous avez un boîtier vous le marque un
boîtier en titane ultra résistant vous
avez un gps double fréquence ultra haute
précision jusqu'à trente six heures
d'autonomie d'ailleurs même au delà de
ce que vous pouvez monter jusqu'à 60
heures avec le mode faible consommation
d'énergie vous un design qui est
vraiment différent le boîtier beaucoup
plus gros boîtier en titane un peu
costaud vous avez un verre en saphir est
ce qui vous le monde par là ou pas une
digital crohn faire des boutures titane
de 49 mm ça fait vraiment pas rigoler
posez-vous digital crunk un peu plus
grosse le bouton qui est là et vous avez
un bouton de l'autre côté aussi vous
allez voir résistance à l'eau jusqu'à
100 m c'est pas rien testés selon la
norme militaire alors je vous passe la
norme est allé la récente à la poussière
ip66 bref vous indiquer quand même hyper
mastoc résistant pour l'extérieur un
écran qui est plus grand et plus
lumineux qui va jusqu'à deux minutes si
vous le montre et puis en plus vous avez
un mode nuit alors le menu en fait c'est
lorsque vous êtes sentiment malagnou
fait du sport en extérieur vous passez
sur le mode nuit et pas voir ce qui va
venir un peu flash et la nuit dans un
endroit où il n'y a pas de lumière vous
êtes plutôt tranquille c'est pas mal et
vous avez ce petit bouton là le petit
bouton d'action qui est tout nouveau qui
vous permet il vous marquez forme et
rapide d'activé de nombreuses fonctions
contrôler un exercice placé un repère
bref on aura différentes façons de venir
utiliser on a deux haut parleurs un
deuxième haut parleurs qui a été rajouté
qui donnera plus de volume sonore si par
exemple dans un endroit où il ya
beaucoup de vent ça pourrait être
extrêmement pratique une sirène qui émet
un signal sonore de 86 décibels pour
attirer l'attention vous êtes a entendue
dans un rayon de 180 m on peut tout à
fait quand même pas mal si jamais vous
avez un souci vous êtes en pleine galère
il ya trois micro alors l'idée de ces
trois micros c'est de venir permettent
d'améliorer la captation du son est ce
que vous vous allez parler à quelqu'un
lorsqu'il ya beaucoup de vent on pense
une fois de plus à l'outdoor si vous
êtes en pleine montagne cas durant au
moins on pourra vous comprendre le
bouton latéral copti et facilement
élégant ça soit extrêmement pratique
aussi le profondimètre qui va afficher
la profondeur sous marine en temps réel
jusqu'à 40 mètres ainsi que la
température de l'eau envoyé à plein de
fonctions qui sont destinés à différents
types de sports on pense à des gants
avec un plus gros boutons on pense à la
plongée alors elle nous parle d'une
application qui s'appelle océanique plus
qui vous donnera même aux paliers de
décompression qui vous dit un an d'un
statut montre là trop vas-y doucement
remonte mais peuvent pas poster deux
minutes vous pourrez ensuite venir
partager toutes vos données de vos
plongées fin juin vachement cool l'inde
et l'autonomie il faut parler à quelques
instants alors bientôt un c'est une
formalité qui je pense va arriver d'un
point de vue software différents types
de bracelets la boucle alpine ou le
bracelet océans la boucle serait il un
chacun choisira ce qui lui plaît et
après ils vous donnent des exemples la
voyez aucune limite de l'endurance pour
courir 10 km d'un ultramarathon bref
vous avez vraiment une mon tout terrain
c'est vraiment l'idée ici un gps aussi
qui ou de nouvelles voies alors vous
connaissez ces systèmes de gps qui vous
dira ok vous êtes là voilà le chemin que
vous avez fait je vous indique votre
itinéraire pour retourner là où vous
étiez ça peut être vachement pratique
parce que si on court ou qu'on se perd
ou dans la montagne eh bien on voit le
chemin pour retourner à sa position
initiale ça c'est pas une faveur en
termes de sécurité de praticité tout ça
vachement bien une boussole qui était
aussi complètement retravaillée alors à
venir voir j'espère que cette monde de
pouvoir l'essayer pour regarder et vous
en dire davantage voyait température de
- 20 55 degrés autant vous dire que je
pense que là on a de quoi faire un duo
d'une montagne jusqu'à la fournaise du
sart toute la partie plongée dont je
vous parlais quelques instants la
certification reconnue pour les
profondimètre et les ordinateurs de
plongée on a tout ce qu'il faut ici pour
la plongée vous parlez de la peau c'est
annick plus à quelques instants le
nouveau capteur de température qui est
là aussi le suivi du sommeil le cg les
notifications santé cardiaque l'oxygène
120 bref on a tout ce qu'on connaît et
ce qu'on aime d apple walsh détection
des accidents la détection des chutes
les appels d'urgence ils ont tout
intégré c'est l'apple watch extrêmement
pour que presque dire ça c'est l'ultra
elle est très certainement pas fait pour
vous allez faites pour les sportifs et
surtout je vous dis une fois de plus une
nouvelle façon d'apple de venir se dire
ok on vient toucher un nouveau segment
vient de toucher une nouvelle personne
on vient toucher les sportifs les plus
extrêmes les hardcore sportifs ceux qui
vont le plus loin ceux qui ont besoin de
montrer encore plus exigeante et qui ont
des besoins très particuliers en fait
l'idée ici c'est de se dire apple il
couvrait sa du marché il leur manquait
ça ils sont venus le chercher ils sont
venus élargir leur gamme avec un tout
nouveau produit tout ça très cool parce
que lorsque j'ai suivi la conférence dit
ok bon il ya une nouvelle apple watch
series huit mois les capteurs
température c'est bien petite nouveauté
ok la pauvreté se sait très bien qu'elle
soit de retour broie qu'une nouvelle
génération ok je reste un peu sur ma
faim d'autant plus que l'année dernière
sur l'apple watch spéciales es7 qui sur
ma faim je dis ouais elle est pas mal
mais par rapport à la 6ème place truc
voyez mise à part l'écran pour y avait
pas le truc là ils ont mis le paquet
avec l' ultra c'est autre chose on va
pouvoir se tester j'espère dans de
nouvelles conditions et je pense et je
pense très honnêtement que c'est un truc
qui va vraiment venir toucher une
nouvelle cible est probablement des
marques comme garmin qui font démontre
un peu comme ça et bien vous dire ah
merde ah les cons ils sont là ok
travaillons dans le line up la 2022 la
balle aux world series 8 là et cela
ultra il y en a un peu pour tous les
tarifs ça reste quand même relativement
cher mais tout ça pas mal on voit la
différence entre la série 8 l'essor du
41 45 la s e 40 44 et là on voit que
cela eût tracé du 49 c'est juste fatah
c'est énorme mais on a tout ce qu'il
faut tout ce qui va bien moi je trouve
très très chouette un très très beau
line up très très belles annonces
montrent très belles annonces smartphone
également vous invite à aller voir ma
vidéo sur les nouveaux iphone 14 iphone
14h14 plus effet 14 3 14 promax aller
jeter un oeil et puis il ya eu également
des nouveaux ipod ce pro de 2e
génération on en reparlera
ultérieurement et testera et on va dire
ça de plus près donc je vous invite à
venir vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà
le cas pour tout savoir il joue pareil
toutes ces nouveautés d'apple contestera
très bientôt et penser actionner la
cloche pour un spotify dès qu une
prochaine vidéo arrivera quant à nous on
se retrouve très bientôt dites moi ce
que vous pensez de ces nouvelles montres
d'apple est ce qu'elle vous intéresse
vous voyais pas du tout ce cas des
choses qui vous surprennent qui vous
intéressent plus que d'autres marques et
moi tout ça juste en bas en commentaire
on se retrouve très bientôt pour
continuer à parler de texte d'ici là
prenez soin de vous embrasse beaucoup
d'amour ou des bisous à béton
oh
[Musique]